>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Jennifer Harbster: Good morning.
I'm Jennifer Harbster.
I'm a research and
reference specialist
with the science technology division
here at the Library of Congress.
I'd like to welcome you
to today's program; Dawn:
A Journey to the Beginning
of the Solar System.
This program is part of a
series of programs or series
of lectures presented through
partnership between my division
and NASA's Goddard
Space Flight Center.
I'm also happy to report
that this is the ninth year
that the Library has been partnering
with Goddard and I also want
to remind you of our last program
of the year and it certainly is not
to be missed if you're into Pluto.
Tuesday December 8 from 11:30 to
12:30 right here in the Pickford.
Dennis Rioter, he's
an astrophysicist
and an instrument scientist for
the NASA's New Horizon mission.
He's going to be highlighting some
of those first close
up images of Pluto.
So it's going to be a
highly illustrated lecture
and I hope you can attend.
But today we are learning
about the Dawn mission,
to the giant asteroid Vesta
and the dwarf planet Ceres.
It's my pleasure today
and an honor today
to introduce today's speaker Dr
Lucy McFadden, a planetary scientist
who investigates the surface
composition of asteroids, comets,
meteorites, as well as our own
satellite, which is our moon
and of those moons of Jupiter.
Dr McFadden is currently a
co-investigator on the Dawn mission
which seeks to unlock some of the
mysteries of planetary formation
by studying Vesta and Ceres.
She also leads Goddard's higher
education and university programs,
facilitating the training
of the next generation
of stem professionals
for the sciences
and exploration director at Goddard.
Dr McFadden received
her undergraduate degree
at Hampshire College in Amherst
Massachusetts where she took a class
on optical and radio astronomy
that changed her life.
She received her master's degree in
earth and planetary science at MIT
and a doctorate in
geology and geophysics
from the University of Hawaii.
So when I was writing this
introduction I had a really hard
time picking out all these
accomplishments to highlight
that Dr McFadden has done so
far in her amazing career.
So I thought I would
do some Cliff Notes.
So one of her accomplishments is
she is a founding and past director
of the College Parks
Scholars program,
science discovery in the universe.
She also is the co-editor of the
Encyclopedia of the Solar System,
the first and second editions,
which we have in the
science reference collection.
She also was a research professor
from the department of astronomy
at the University of Maryland.
She was a member of the science team
for the NEAR Earth Asteroid
Rendezvous mission which orbited
and landed on the asteroid 433 Eros.
She's a co-investigator
on the Deep Impact mission
that investigated comets.
She's also collected
meteorites in Antarctica
and she has an asteroid
named after her;
asteroid 3066 is named McFadden.
So please now join me in
welcoming Dr Lucy McFadden
to the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> Lucy McFadden: Thank
you Jennifer.
It's a pleasure to be here
and an honor to be invited
to give this lecture today and I
just hope you'll share the journey
and the excitement of discovery that
my team members and I have engaged
in in the past numerous years.
It's actually has been
a 15 year journey.
I was sitting here staring at
my cover slide and want to point
out that the Dawn mission
is a partnership.
It's a NASA mission,
but it's a partnership
with scientific leadership
at UCLA and I'm going
to read across from the bottom.
It is managed by the Jet
Propulsion Laboratory at Cal Tech.
Our spacecraft, our
little spacecraft that can
and favorite was built by
Orbital, which was merged a couple
of months ago and is
now Orbital ATK.
We have instruments provided
by the Italian Space Agency
and the German Space Agency, DLR and
those are, and the camera is managed
by the Max Planck Institute,
which is MPS and Veer is managed
by Institut Nasional for
astrophysical in Rome.
So I'm part of a team and
I'm here to share what we've,
what are team has done
so far with you.
Because it's a tough time out
in the world, I want to set,
give us some cosmic relief.
Let's go out beyond Ceres and look
back toward the sun and I'm going
to work my way out so,
from the sun working
out you can see the inter planets,
the terrestrial planets; Mercury,
Venus, Earth with its moons,
and Mars and the orbits.
Their orbits are drawn in here
in this artist rendition just
to remind us that everything
in the solar system orbits
the sun and elliptical paths.
And then we have the
asteroid belt, which the,
which our artist here has designated
and so you can see all these
fragments of the asteroid belt
that were growing into planets, but
that planet growth was disrupted
when Jupiter migrated in
toward the sun and resulted
in gravitational disruption
that caused a lot of collisions
of which many and most of
the asteroids are fragments
from those collisions, but there
are a couple of larger asteroids
that have remained intact since
the beginning of the solar system
over four and a half
billion years ago.
So here in the fore ground in the
lower right is a representation
of Ceres as we knew
it before we arrived.
You can see it has some
fuzzy little lobes around it.
Sort of looks like lungs and the
Herschel, the Herschel observatory,
European observatory
has observed and couple
of years ago some evidence
of out gassing
of water associated with Ceres.
So we were eager to get to Ceres
and see what the Dawn mission
could, could reveal to us.
Prior to getting there, we had
used the Hubble space telescope.
So again, a partnership of
all the resources available
around the world.
We studied, we imaged both Vesta
and Ceres with the Hubble telescope
and observed it as, it over time
and observed changes with its,
as it rotated and you can see
here slight, subtle changes
in the color for each object.
And you should see first off
that Ceres is more or less round
and Vesta is more or less
not round and it sort
of has a bite taken
out of the bottom.
And it's for this reason
that the IAU
in 2006 deemed Ceres a dwarf
planet because it's round
and gravitationally relaxed and
has cleared its region around it
and Vesta is still an asteroid.
It's not gravitationally relaxed.
It's not round and we figured
out why with the Dawn mission.
So next I want to give, pay tribute
to our satellite, the spacecraft.
We call it the Dawn spacecraft.
It is powered by ion propulsion.
Ions, it has a tank full of
Zenon, which is an inert gas
and the Zenon pushes out,
thrusts out the ions behind it
and it gives the spacecraft
and equal and opposite force
in the other direction
and it thrusts
and moves the spacecraft
through space.
We couldn't have done what we have
done without this ion propulsion.
Every thrust sort of gives the
force of a piece of paper sitting
in your hand, but that force
is added up to the spacecraft.
It keeps moving and you get a little
bit of change in velocity as it goes
and so over the seven years of
its time in space, it has thrusts
over 50,000 times for, I'm sorry
thrusts for 50,000 hours, I'm sorry,
for a total of about 5.7 years and
that has resulted in a high velocity
that is allowed the spacecraft
to get out to where we're going.
With only using the
mass of the Zenon
in the tank as a propulsion device.
If we had used conventional chemical
propulsion called hydrazine it
would've weighed too much and
we would have not been able
to launch it at the cost
of the Discovery mission.
So our ion, our ion engines got
the spacecraft to where it's going,
but it took us seven
years to get there.
So we traded off cost for time,
but hey it gave me a great,
you know I was, it happened
at the right time in my career
so I was able to see it at the end.
So while it's in space,
the spacecraft is powered
by solar panels.
We've, the spacecraft has travelled
to over three times the distance
from the, three times the
distance of the earth to the sun.
So it's far away.
It needed large solar panels
to collect enough sunlight
to get enough energy to
power the instruments.
So the solar panels
are 65 feet long.
To put that to scale, when
I moved from Baltimore
to California many years ago,
I put my family's furniture
in a moving van that
was 70 feet long.
It carried three families
worth of junk or furniture,
but to scale that's like a long
semi, 16 wheeler semi-trailer.
Our instruments are the eyes and
ears and nose of the spacecraft.
Include a camera, a framing
camera that was provided
by our German colleagues and led
by Andres Natuse at
Max Planck Institute.
Our gamma ray and neutron
spectrometers are American made
and headed up by Thomas Prettyman
who, he built the spectrometers
at Los Alamos National Laboratory
and he's now operating it
from the Planetary Science
Institute in Tucson Arizona.
And then our visible and infrared
mapping spectrometers built
by our Italian colleagues is
led by Christina Desanktus
and they had it built with
Italian, by an Italian company
under Christina's direction
and they are now operating it.
we also consider the antenna on
the spacecraft as an instrument
because the antenna sends back
signals that give us the location,
the precise location of
the spacecraft and from
that information we derive
gravitational maps and information
about the gravity field
of our targets and so
that allows us to study
the interior.
So the antennas are sort
of forth instrument.
We launched, okay so our spacecraft
was launched on a Delta-2 rocket
from Cape Canaveral and have
any of you had the opportunity
to see a spacecraft launch?
Do any of you think of, okay good.
Have, what is better than
watching a spacecraft launch?
[Laughter] Never mind, we
better not answer that.
[Laughter] So, but if you
even have a chance to,
you know go to see a spacecraft
launch, it's really pretty exciting.
And this is a photograph of the
launch at the launch pad at night.
Okay, this is not, this is not
a model, even though I have one
on my desk at home, but this is,
this was it the night
before we launched.
All lite up.
We went out to the, we
went out to check on it
and the mosquitos were horrific
so take DEAT when you go
and then the next morning
we were fortunate
to have the weather conditions
such that we could launch.
And we launched at dawn
on September 27, 2007.
Okay so here we are in
2015, eight years later.
Let me show you our path.
So let's see, Dawn launches in
at the earth and we spiraled
out past Mars a year later and
then had a three year cruise
to Vesta and arrived in 2011.
Spent a year orbiting Vesta
and I'll tell you about that
and while Vesta itself moved in its
orbit around the sun, so we spiraled
around it and left for another
three year cruise and arrived
at Ceres in March of 2015.
Yes so we're, so my
story will not end
yet because we haven't ended
the mission and we're still
in this interpretation phase,
which you'll hear about shortly.
So Dawn is the first mission
to orbit a main belt asteroid.
We had orbited a smaller near
earth asteroid back in 2000,
but this was the first main
belt asteroid and I think,
I just want to let
this, here's summation
of our observations of Vesta.
So the spacecraft, I'm
sorry the asteroid is orbit,
is rotating on its axis one day on
Vesta is five hours and 20 minutes.
So we're lucky we don't
live on Vesta.
[Laughter] We'd never feel
like we got anything done.
So I almost want to say
well what do you see
as the spacecraft is rotating?
>> It's shaped like a mountain.
>> Shaped like a lemon, good.
There are mountains.
[ Inaudible Response ]
There's streak down the center.
There's something going across,
I can play it one more time.
I think I have time to
play it one more time.
There's streaks going around
the equator or at an angle.
Those are compressional
tectonic features.
Here's another set of
lineations at the equator.
We do see a lot of craters to
begin with and that mountain
at the southern hemisphere,
that mountain is a big basin.
Oh there are those three,
three craters that sort
of look like a snowman.
We had a Christmas card
and we put a snowman on it.
[Laughter] Okay so let's take a
look at some of these features.
I'm going to go down to the
southern basin to that mountain,
which is really the central
peak of a large crater.
It's, okay.
There we go, okay.
So now, now we've taken our images
with a digital terrain model
that we derived from all the images
and laid, lay the, we color coded it
for the altitude from the
center of Vesta, okay?
So the blue is the
deepest part of this basin
and it's 14 miles below the mean,
you know sea level on the asteroid,
they don't call it sea
level, but the mean geoid.
So it's 14 miles deep and the peak
of the mountain in
red is 12 miles high.
So this peak is more than
twice as high as Mount Everest.
Well that's not surprising
because there's not
as much gravity on Vesta.
Vesta is 250 kilometers across.
If I were to lay that onto
a map of the United States,
it would sort of fit across
the state of Texas, okay.
So this is a small body.
So there's not much gravity.
So if you have an impact
and you have an impact
and something rebounds without much
gravity it's going to get very big.
But still, this is pretty,
this was pretty spectacular.
We saw evidence of it from
Hubble and when you think
about it you say wow, it's
amazing that Vesta is still intact.
You know, that it's still a whole
body and not total fragments.
Well it turns out it was formed
by these, by huge impacts
in the southern hemisphere, in
the southern hemisphere and debris
from that impact created a
family of Vesta asteroids
and there are hundreds of
smaller asteroids that are
about 50 kilometers across.
One-fifth or smaller the diameter
of Vesta that are in orbits
that are close, similar to Vesta.
And in fact, throughout the
age of the solar system,
this probably happened four,
three or four billion years ago.
Some people say maybe
it, a billion years ago.
Smaller debris has been
scattered across the solar system
under gravitational influences
from other planets like Mars
and other asteroids and in fact
there have been many pieces of Vesta
like asteroid fragments
that have landed on earth.
And in fact, one in every
seven meteorites that we have
in our meteorite collection
is from Vesta.
>> How do you know that?
>> Lucy McFadden: We know
that from, we know that from,
we take the meteorites in here that
we have in our hand and in our labs.
We shine a simulated sun on it
and look at the reflected light
that gives us spectral signature.
It's like the finger print
from these meteorites.
They're called basaltic
achondrite meteorites.
We also, we also name them HEDs
because they have names based
on the first type, that's
probably extraneous information.
But then, so we have
the reflected signature.
This is my, the thumb print of
these meteorites and we look
at the reflected sunlight
from Vesta itself
and it has the diagnostic signatures
of these reflectance spectra.
So they are identical.
That's the first reason.
The second reason is that
we have dynamical models.
We can predict the
gravitational changes,
pushes and shoves throughout the
age of the solar system that show
that fragments from Vesta
can migrate into a region
of the asteroid belt, a
resonance that will sent them
on a direct path to earth.
So that's the second and then
the third aspect is that we see,
that we see trace amounts of
fragments within these meteorites
that we also see evidence
for from the Dawn mission.
So we're pretty certain
and there are no other,
there are no other large objects
in the asteroid belt besides Vesta
and the Vestoids family that have
these same spectral signatures.
So then my colleagues, my geologist
colleagues took, got their hands
on all the images from Vesta and
they start making geological maps.
So they take, based on the surface
features and the relationships
of various flows and the
density of the craters.
So here's a geological map of
Vesta with a time sequence.
I'm going to start in the
upper left, the green,
the Marcia crater material
is the most recent.
It's young.
There are very few
craters on top of it.
So it's the youngest material.
Then the yellow and red to the
blue is material from Rhea Silvia,
which was that, the southern
hemisphere formation.
I'm sorry I didn't bring a
pointer and, oh no here's a gavel.
[ Laughter ]
So there's the Rhea Silvia material
from that impact that was spread
and you can see it covered most of
the southern hemisphere because most
of it that's blue material
that covers part
of the southern hemisphere.
And then the Venenata,
there's another basin
beneath the Rhea Silvia basin.
There are actually two basins.
Oh thank you.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Lucy McFadden: There's a
formation beneath Rhea Silvia
that is the oldest material.
So we have --
>> It's not working.
It doesn't --
>> Lucy McFadden: There we go.
There we go.
So this is the oldest material
is in the purple and the brown,
which is cratered highlands
and we've also marked some
of the tectonic features that
are caused by the giant impact.
Here's, here are tectonic features
from the older Venenata
impact that go here.
So we have the geologist who, you
know we now have a time sequence
and we have special resolution
that we couldn't see before.
Another, I'm going to give you two
other, two other significant results
from Vesta before we
move onto Ceres.
Here's the map of reflectance beyond
the region where our eye can see.
Out beyond one micron and this
reflectance shows variations
in brightness across the surface.
Part of it is brighter and here's
a dark region in the center
and another bright region here.
We could see this from our
ground based telescopes,
but we didn't know
what it was caused by.
So from the Dawn mission, I
think we have a good idea.
This dark material here also has
a, is correlated with the presence
of an absorption feature
in the spectrum
that is due to OH bearing species.
So hydrated species, not water
itself, but hydrated species.
That's, so we got evidence
from our spectrometer
that this darker stuff has an
absorption due to hydrated minerals.
We also found correlation
with a certain type
of those basaltic achondrites
because they come in
different flavors.
Those meteorites that come from
Vesta come in different flavors.
Basically three, three
different flavors; blue, green,
and red, but they have names.
Eucrites, Howardites, and
Diogenites, but this region here
of the Eucrites is the ancient crust
and has more of this dark material
in it and these meteorites, when
we look at them here on earth,
they also have small
amounts of this dark material
from carbonation chondrites
that are dark and hydrated.
And then our third evidence
that supports this is our,
from our gamma ray neutron maps.
I'm sorry I don't have them at the
same scale, however, the foot print
of these, of this neutron
spectrometer is much larger.
So I can't give it the same
detail, but you can certainly see
in this region between about 60
and about 120 degrees longitude
that this region has
an overabundance
of hydrogen bearing material.
So that's two instruments that
give us this evidence of water,
water bearing species in it.
and then my third set, so in summary
we have the giant basin forming
impacts, redistributed
material all over Vesta.
We have evidence of dark, hydrated,
carbonatious material remnant
from the earlier Venenata
impact that has located,
concentrated between 60
and 120 degrees longitude
and the spacecraft itself, while it
was orbiting Vesta for over a year,
from its gravitational
model was able to determine
that Vesta itself has
a metallic core.
And that's also consistent
with the formation
of these basaltic achondrite
meteorites that we have
because they have had all their
metallic iron removed from them.
So in many cases, after, you know
in many cases Vesta has
many similarities to a very,
small, tiny terrestrial planet.
It has an iron core like the earth.
It's way tinier than the earth.
It has evidence of
basaltic volcanism,
silicate rich material has been
heated during the life of Vesta,
heated and float out on the surface.
Just like volcanic
flows here on earth.
And then the impacting that
occurred throughout the earlier
or the older times of the solar
system has redistributed the
material and sent some of
it here towards us on earth.
So Vesta is very similar,
has similarities
to a terrestrial, earth like planet.
We just finished publishing that
work and it came out last spring
and that took us, it took us a
couple of years and we made good use
of the time while the spacecraft
was cruising onto Ceres.
So let's go onto Ceres.
So it's the first,
the first spacecraft,
our second first of
the Dawn mission.
Arriving at Ceres, we went
into orbit on March 6.
The first thing we did and
this was a project that I led,
was to look for moons around Ceres.
We also looked for
moons around Vesta.
We didn't find anything down
to about 30 meters on Vesta,
so there's nothing orbiting
like a moon around our earth
or around Mars, which has two moons.
So at Ceres we looked and here on
the left is a night sky projected
at the same scale as our
camera on the Dawn spacecraft.
So our, and we've highlighted
a couple of stars here
and you cannot see Ceres, but here
on the right is an image on approach
to Ceres taken by our camera and
it's not pretty because I want
to look at all the flaws
and everything and make sure
that I know what I'm looking
at and make sure I'm looking
for a tiny object that's
moving around Ceres.
So I'm looking at everything and
checking everything that we see
and make sure it's either an
artifact on my camera or something
or an object, a star, or
something with motion.
Now if I just look at one, so I've
highlighted some of the objects.
This is an artifact of
the readout on the camera.
It's a CCD camera and we just can't,
there's so much signal here it
doesn't get read out clearly.
Here's, this is, circled in red
is an artifact on the image.
It would take, we took hundreds
of images and we devised a method
where we add the images that
in time focusing on Ceres.
Here we've got Ceres
off at the edge.
We're not interested in Ceres,
but here we've added 64 images
that are registered on Ceres and
since the spacecraft is moving
in space, these background
stars will move themselves
and so they form trails.
So then with this image we're set
with looking for things that are,
that are moving in a
different direction,
but have the same pattern
as the background stars.
So then we scan these
registered images looking
for something going
in another direction.
Does anyone see anything
that's moving, that's a skewed
from all of those others?
There's maybe that one,
but what's wrong with that?
That's only one dash.
There's no, there has to be
four of them to be, to be real.
Well, we've looked,
we scan it completely.
Here's another, these
are cosmic rays.
Here's a single spot
that's a hot pixel.
So we scan these and these
unfortunately we haven't found
anything, but then we say
well how deep can we see?
And so we calculate the
faintest, the brightness
of the faintest asteroid, assume
it has the albedo of Ceres
and we determine that we have
searched the space around Ceres
down to between 20 and
300 meters in diameter.
So there are no, unfortunately
there are no moons around,
around Ceres either.
So here's some basics,
things to know about Ceres.
It rotates.
It rotates more slowly than Vesta.
It rotates about once
every 10 hours.
It's about 590 miles across, oh
and now I have to correct myself.
On a map of the United States,
it's Ceres that's almost a 1,000
kilometers that is the width of,
that's the width of Texas
and Vesta is the width
of the States of Arizona.
Okay so sorry about that.
The surface temperature at Ceres
is between 130 and 200 Kelvin,
where 300 Kelvin is
temperature at earth.
Okay so it's cold.
That's important because if you had
water ice sitting on the surface
of Ceres, it would sublimate.
It's not stable.
However, Ceres as a whole
has about 25% water.
Someone please ask me
how do I know that.
[ Inaudible Response ]
How do I know that?
Thank you.
That was determined from the
relationship between its density
and its shape derived
from Hubble observations.
It is basically round.
You are looking at it here
as basically round, however,
when you carefully measure
the, its axis of the equatorial
to the polar axis, it's
not perfectly round.
It's, the earth is oblique, but
Ceres is a little bit inflated.
It's a little bit inflated and
that combined with knowledge
of its density, which is 2.1 grams
per cubic centimeter whereas the
earth's crust has a density of
3.3 grams per cubic centimeter.
That density being less than
three tells us that there has
to be a significant amount of water
in the whole bulk composition
of Ceres.
Yet, if water were on the
surface it wouldn't stay.
It wouldn't remain.
So from our thermal models
that my colleagues Tom McCord
and Julie Casteo have done, it's,
it may have some liquid water
in its interior, but
not on its surface
and the surface reflects only
about 10% of incident sunlight.
It's basically dark.
Vesta, in contrast, reflected
36% of the sunlight that hits it.
Many of you may have seen we
did make the papers last spring
for these two bright headlights.
So those are, they will,
I will talk about those.
There were a couple of other
bright spots that we see.
There's some smooth plains,
but it is a cratered surface,
but still very different,
very different from Vesta.
So let's what we've learned.
So our geologist, our
mappers have created our map
and I'm sorry this one doesn't
have, this is zero degrees longitude
over here and 360 over here.
There is a big, bright feature
that is right on the edge.
So sometimes we project
it differently.
Here's the bright crater that has
bright material in the center,
but also ejecta bright material
that has been ejected from it.
looking at this, you know
is this something that was,
came from outside and
hit, when it hit it splat
and it's bright material?
Or is it something from
inside of Vesta, I'm sorry,
Ceres when it was brought up from
beneath the surface and spread out?
So that's a question that
you may have and a question
that the scientists too are having.
Then we have, looking at the
edge as Ceres rotates around.
We saw this little lonely mountain.
This is three kilometers above the
sphere and we're, that was another,
it was initially called the pyramid.
We quickly got to talk to the
International Astronomical Union
who controls, who approves our names
and we gave it a name of Ahuna Mons
and all of the features on, all
of the craters on Ceres are named
after the Goddesses or Gods and
Goddesses related to the harvest
because Ceres is the
Goddess of the harvest.
So we're now in the process,
my post-doc is modeling the
distribution of the height
with respect to this mountain
to try and determine what type
of mechanisms could produce this.
We see that the top here,
the top flattened part
of the mountain is similar to
the surrounding cratered terrain
and these are very steep slopes and
so it looks like it's an extrusion.
Something that pushed up from
beneath the surface and did
so relatively recently because this,
all these steep slopes are
pretty fresh, but we're working
on an interpretation of
that formation mechanism.
Then here's our close up of
the bright spots, which were,
which exist inside the
crater named Occator
and so this is quite a
nice high resolution image.
The two bright spots resolved into
about eight other smaller spots
with debris spread around it.
When I look on my screen, I can
see in the center here there seems
to be something that's dome
like right in the middle
and we have determined the
brightness, this material is,
reflects 50% of the
light that hits it.
Whereas the surrounding reflects
nine to 10% of the light.
It's clearly inside of this crater.
These crater walls are interesting.
They're not quite, most craters
are circular, but this has a lot
of structure in it and that
tells us that the surface
of Ceres has some strength,
but it's not a lot of strength
because you get collapse
and things falling.
There's also some, at least on
my screen, I can see cracks,
well maybe they're here and we're,
so the science team is really
in the process of trying to figure
out what this means and coming
up with a good story that fits
with the physical mechanisms.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Response ]
Well, yeah we have general
theories it could be something
from outside that, you know that or
it could be something from beneath
and help me, what do you think of?
What are the first things you think
of because guaranteed those are
the same things that we think of.
>> Sulfur.
>> Lucy McFadden: Sulfur,
okay because that's bright.
We, you know we know it's bright.
That's certainly one possibility.
Anything else?
What else is bright?
I mean the ice, ice, we first,
we look at the ice even though
our thermal dynamic models tell us
that ice is not likely to be there.
We're certainly going to look
for the spectral signature
of ice, of water ice.
Maybe some other ices.
There's some, yes.
>> Do you get any information of
what, you know the material is
by shooting, you know
getting spectral --
>> Lucy McFadden: Right,
we do have the spectra,
but we are in the process
of interpreting that
and the science team right
now is having discussions
about the interpretations.
So there's one other thing.
So think about on earth
there's a place on earth --
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Salt.
>> Lucy McFadden: Salt, yes.
>> Carbonated.
>> Lucy McFadden: Salt
carbonates, that's a good one too.
Those are good too
and so the silicates,
I think the silicates give
the whole body the strength,
but again they could be different.
There are many different
kinds of silicates.
So it could be something unique.
And so the science team literally
as I'm speaking now is having a
mineralogy working group discussion
about the possible interpretations.
So I don't, I don't have an answer
and it's not an easy problem.
Our spectrometer has, does have
spectra of these, but we're still,
we, there's no point in
releasing the spectra
until we have an interpretation
to go with it.
So I'm going to have to ask for your
patience and you know we're having,
they're under discussion.
Now, what we have released today is
the, our mosaics of both the north
and south polar regions on Ceres.
So these are mosaics
that were put together
from our high altitude mapping
orbit and I guess I should've said
that we have, we have
mission phases.
We have the survey where
we're at 4,700 kilometers,
no we were more than that.
We were 12,000 kilometers
at survey and then we went
down to high altitude orbit.
We literally spiral down
and in, these are mosaics
from our high altitude orbit,
which is about 2,700 kilometers,
if I remember correctly.
And at, in the North Pole,
in the North Pole we
found one more mountain.
We've named it Usolo Mons and
so Ceres now has two mountains
and we weren't expecting
any, but there are two.
But why only two?
And then here, and I stare at this,
the more you stare at it I see sort
of some large, maybe large basin
edges, rims of basins, but again,
our geological mappers
will be looking at these
and building geological maps.
In the southern hemisphere,
okay here's this large,
large crater that may be called a
basin and then some other ridges
and it will all be large craters
with smaller craters in the middle,
with peaks on them, and then this
is a region with no data at all
because of the viewing geometry.
Now, an interesting thing,
so this is now it's
winter at this South Pole.
So these were taken at Ceres summer.
So interesting thing, I think
I have a minute to do this is
on the earth our seasons
are controlled by the axis
at which the earth
tilts, the 23.5 degrees.
Ceres tilts only four
degrees on its axis.
So we shouldn't get many, much
of a season except that the orbit
of Ceres itself has a 10
degree inclination with respect
to the earth, with the respect to
the plain and the sun and the earth.
So this 10 degrees tilt
and the fact that Ceres is
down here now prevents
the sunlight from getting
to the whole southern hemisphere.
That it would change
if we were up here.
So that's, here I do have
some of my spectral imaging.
Again, no spectra, but our spectral
imaging spectrometer has 800
channels of data and in each
channel you get an image of Ceres.
Now this was Ceres on approach,
okay so we were far away,
but look at this sequence of
visible, infrared, and thermal.
These are two different spots.
Here you can see a bright spot
here and this is actually Occator
and in some displays you can see
that the infrared is a little
bit brighter in Occator.
It's a little bit red and then here
it's clearly dark in the thermal.
So that means that's it's colder
in this thermal image
than everything else.
So it's reflecting much of its light
such that it's cooler
than the surroundings.
Now, down here at this bright spot,
which I believe is Halani crater,
it's bright in the visible,
it's bright in the infrared,
but it's also bright in
the thermal infrared.
So it's bright and hot whereas
Occator is bright and cold.
Now that's a clue too.
That's going to, when we untangle
our interpretations we have to take
into account that not
all the bright spots
on Ceres are the same
composition of the same material.
So there's things going on,
but unfortunately we
just sort of say huh?
We're not quite sure yet and
in fact, I was just last week
at a meeting in, down
at National Harbor
and someone Tweeted
saying I just looked at a,
someone who had heard the
results of, from Ceres
and they were staring blankly
and they said I don't get it
and the science team in
is in the same situation.
We'll just have to argue back and
forth and arrive at something.
So Ceres on the interior, we do,
I'm mentioning there is evidence
that some of, instead
of water we may have,
well we know we have water,
but there may also be ammonia.
Ammoniated species,
ammoniated silicates
and our thermal models give a
possible internal structure that's
similar to this with an
icy mantel and a rocky core
and there may be some
liquid water present,
but we won't be able to detect that.
Now with the fact, with
the fact that we're trying
to create a coherent story about the
surface composition, the processes,
the active processes that form
the surface of Ceres here,
we're questioning now whether with
the fact that we don't have a lot
of icy material on
it, on the surface
and that we find ammoniated species
that come from farther away from,
that are stable at the outer
parts of the solar system.
We're asking ourselves was Ceres
formed here in the asteroid belt.
If it was formed in the asteroid
belt and it picked up some
of these colder, ammoniated
species from the outer solar system,
was that material deposited onto
Ceres in the early solar system
or was Ceres itself formed far out
beyond, in the outer solar system
and migrated in as a complete body?
We hope we'll have some answers,
but those are our fundamental
questions right now.
>> Where is Pluto on this depiction?
[ Laughter ]
>> Lucy McFadden: Over there.
Okay so today, today the Dawn
spacecraft is in the process of,
these are orbits of the Dawn
spacecraft as it spirals down.
So at the end of October,
we began our descent
into our low altitude mapping orbit.
We're probably down maybe around
here and we will continue spiraling
down to an orbit of 850 kilometers
and in mid-December we'll get our,
we'll get our highest resolution
images, but we'll also get results
from our gamma ray
and neutron detector
which will give us some
compositional information,
elemental compositional information.
We'll know about the
distribution of hydrogen
to see whether these
species are hydrated.
Hopefully we'll be able to get
some ratios that will allow us
to disentangle the carbonates.
There are some signatures
due to carbonates.
There are also signatures
due to ammoniated silicates
or clays with ammonia in them.
So we do have more data coming
back to us until the end of,
until the end of June and we
have an opportunity in the spring
to write a proposal to
NASA headquarters to ask
for an extended mission where we
would plan to see what we can do
if we stay longer and if
we can target certain areas
with certain sets of
instrumental observations to try
and resolve some of our ambiguities.
What's holding us, what's
keeping us going are the engineers
who have been keeping
track of our fuel levels.
We had, throughout the
course of the mission, there,
we've had some breakdowns.
They haven't been catastrophic, but
we had reaction wheels that failed
so that the stability
of the spacecraft is
not what it used to be.
So we're operating on two
reaction wheels instead of four
and the navigation team devised a
method to save our hydrazine fuel
and so at LAMO we're going to
start using the hydrazine fuel
to stabilize us so that we can
get clear, clear stable pictures.
So here's our fuel tank.
We've got, we're at half, we're half
full and we're going to us it all
up before the mission ends.
As I said, I just want to give
a shout out to my team mates.
This was definitely a team effort.
We meet, we're from all over
the world, we meet a couple
of times a year in person.
We spend time on the phone every
week and then sometimes some
of us will, some of us dress up
pretty well, especially when the Air
and Space Museum gives them an
award for achievement in space
and this is our project and
navigation team a couple
of years ago, 2014 when
they received an award
for their efforts at Vesta.
So thank you for your
attention and we have materials
on the website for your information.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible Response ]
Sure.
>> Jennifer Harbster:
A question, sure.
>> Lucy McFadden: In the back,
the gentlemen in the back have
their hands up first and I'd
like to alternate between
taking questions
from men and women, if possible.
>> In Vesta, you've got the
real steep crater at the bottom,
but you've got a big huge
crater up at the top.
Could it be that, the mountain
on the bottom is a push
out from the bottom from
the hit from that top?
>> Lucy McFadden: Right.
We've thought about that.
Is it antipodal?
The opposite and I
think the gravity,
the gravity models
do not support that,
but we definitely looked into that.
But we didn't see evidence of that.
>> Okay thank you.
>> Lucy McFadden: Oh and I
should have reported the,
repeated the question which was
[laughter], which was is it possible
that the, that there could be
an effect from the giant impact
in the southern hemisphere that's
observable 180 degrees opposite it
in the northern hemisphere?
Okay so I'll follow directions.
Okay gentlemen, who was left
and then I'll come down here.
>> You said that propulsion
is it just releasing pressure
out of the tank or does
it actually burn the fuel?
I think [inaudible] --
>> Lucy McFadden: The
propulsion, okay the question --
>> Then how did it slow when you got
to the point of it actually orbited?
Because I know when Pluto
was a fly by [inaudible].
>> Lucy McFadden: Right, okay.
So the question was about the fuel
and how, what the mechanism is
of producing the thrust on the
spacecraft and then following,
the second part was how
did we slow it down.
So the fuel is sending the ions,
the Zenon is ionized
and forced out the back.
It's forced out through the
nozzle of the ion engine
as a charged Zenon
particle and Zenon is heavy.
It has mass and it's accelerated
through magnetic fields
and that gives it a force.
So there's no chemical reaction
that produces the energy.
It's produced by magnetic
fields and the direction
in which the thruster points and
that causes the spacecraft to go
in the opposite direction.
And what we do is match the orbit.
So we are, we are thrusting
away and thrusting away
from the gravitational force of
the sun and so we're spiraling
out the whole time and then we
match orbits with our targets.
So and the thing is, the
thing that's hard to grasp is
that this is just tiny, little
changes with every little puff,
you know every little
ejection of the Zenon ions.
And it's just that it took seven
years and so we didn't really have
to slow it down, we
just matched the orbit.
We get there and then also
we changed directions.
You have to change the vector, so
you move the, you move the engines
and point them in a
different direction.
So that's actually how we do it.
It's pointing the direction,
but it's always a thrust.
[ Inaudible Response ]
Well when we got there it, in
fact we had a hard time saying
when do we go into orbit.
We have to declare it
because everybody wanted
to say okay now we're in orbit,
but Ceres is moving around the sun
and we sort of caught up to it.
So it's more like a
dance than driving there.
Yes sir.
>> You mentioned trying to get
money to extend the mission
and I heard the same thing on
the news about the Pluto --
>> Lucy McFadden: Yes.
>> Is it really an option at
NASA not to get every benefit
of these expensive and
rare assets in space?
>> Lucy McFadden: Well the fact
is we're going to be competing.
There's a number of
missions that are competing
and they have this senior
review where we write a proposal
and we have to have
compelling science
because it's your tax payer
dollars and my tax payer dollars
and it's a finite budget.
So we can think of a lot of
things to do, but if we do,
if we do an extended mission
on something then we have
to delay starting something
else or not do something else.
So it's all a matter of
balancing the budget.
Is that correct according
to the people
from NASA headquarters
in the audience?
[ Laughter ]
>> Yes.
>> Lucy McFadden: Thank you
and the, oh shoot I forgot
to repeat the question again.
We'll play Jeopardy on those
of you doing the webcast
will play Jeopardy.
Yes mam.
>> I was intrigued by what you
said the difference in reflectivity
between Vesta and Ceres was
and just from reflectivity
of all the stuff in
the asteroid belt.
Is Ceres an anomaly or can you
tell what the basic composition
of the crust is on these bodies?
>> Lucy McFadden: Okay so the
question was about the differences
in the reflectivity of
Vesta and Ceres and things
in the asteroid belt
and can we tell,
does that tell us anything
about the composition?
So the reflectivity
or the brightness,
it's also called the
albedo, how white it is
because albedo is the
Greek word for white.
So it tells, it constrains
the composition,
but there are many things that are
bright that reflect 50% of sunlight
and so, you know salts,
sulfates, and ice,
but you know we need other
instruments and other information
to constrain those differences.
So we're very much waiting for the
interpretation from the spectrometer
to see whether there are spectral
signatures of ice or sulfates
or water frost on the surface.
And then the difference
between Vesta and Ceres,
most of the asteroids
are dark like Ceres.
In fact, many of the
asteroids are darker.
They reflect about 3% of
the light and that's less
than a charcoal briquette reflects.
So Ceres is dark, but Vesta
is very bright and again,
the difference, I forgot to tie in.
You know I said that Vesta
was like a terrestrial planet,
a small terrestrial planet, but
Ceres has a lot of volatiles
and unusual species that are
stable at colder temperatures.
So there's the big, there's a
temperature regimen difference
in these different parts of the
asteroid belt that plays a big role
in determining the
nature of the surface
and the composition of the material.
So temperature is a big difference.
Yes mam, in the back.
>> For those who are interested in
looking at the relevant data sets
for these two sites, is it easy to
find the data sets within those?
>> Lucy McFadden: Okay the question
was for those of us interested
in seeing the relevant data
sets, is it easy to find them?
These two websites are education
and public outreach websites.
So there's images available that
have been released to the public
and educational material that's
been designed by educators
for various levels, grade levels.
There is a process of placing
the data in an archive,
the National Planetary Data System
archive and that takes time.
We deliver it within six
months of receiving it.
So some of it is delivered and
that's a different website,
the Planetary Data System website
which has the archived data,
the raw images and the spectra
and documentation that explains it
and those are available
for scientists worldwide
or amateur scientist.
They're available for anyone to use.
Thank you for asking.
Yes sir.
[ Inaudible Response ]
No. Iron core in Vesta
because it's bulk density is
about 3.5 grams per
cubic centimeter.
More like the crust of the earth,
but the core of Ceres
has to be silicate rich.
There's not a lot of iron in it.
Just because its density it
lower, its bulk density is lower.
So we don't anticipate a
metallic core in Ceres.
Yeah and that's a good
question, where did the iron go?
Maybe all the dark stuff, maybe
the iron particles bring the
albedo down.
It's a, thank you for
asking that question.
That made me, the question
was what's the composition
of the cores of the two objects.
Okay in the back sir.
>> You said that Ceres had a skew
from [inaudible] by 10 degrees?
Is it alone in that?
Is the rest of the
asteroid belt skewed at all?
>> Lucy McFadden: No, the
question was about the inclination
of the orbit of Ceres with
respect to the earth's sun plain.
The main asteroid belt,
the asteroids have a
range of inclinations.
So Ceres is not unusual
in that regard.
They do vary and they've
been scattered,
there are inclinations
are a result of collisions
and scattering during
the formation process.
So it's not that unusual,
but most of,
you know most of the main belt is
within maybe plus or
minus 10 degrees.
Although there are some with
a 40 degree inclination.
The gentleman down
here with the question.
>> It may be a little early
in your time of the mission,
but have you learned things
that would suggest you might do
things differently the next time you
do something like this?
>> Lucy McFadden: The
question is have I learned,
are there things I've wished we had
done that we haven't done in terms
of having instrumentation on board.
I rephrased your question,
is that adequate?
So absolutely.
We wished we had a magnetometer on
board especially at Vesta to see
if it has a magnetic field
because that would confirm our
interior modeling that suggests
that the core is iron rich.
We could, we would look for a
magnetic field associated with it.
I wish we had another, I wish I
could detect defuse material where,
that would come off the limb.
Defuse gaseous material
because we wanted to see
if Ceres is outgassing
is giving off water
because there's water
in the interior.
If it comes up to the
surface and sublimates,
it would be nice to see it.
I'd like to see if those bright
spots are like a geyser on Ceres,
but our instrumentation doesn't have
the right optics to detect that.
So those are the main things
and of course, I'd want to land
and have a laboratory like the
Mars sample laboratory on Ceres.
Thanks for asking.
Yes mam.
>> Are there are theories about
where the water in the center
of [inaudible] under the crust
comes from or how it is [inaudible]?
>> Lucy McFadden: The
question was are there theories
about where the water
beneath the crust comes
from and how it was created.
So the, we generally wave our hands
about this, but when material is,
the nebular, the solar nebula 4.5
billion years ago was rotating gas
and dust and things were colliding
and they started sticking together
and then you get something nucleated
and then they collide and stick more
and they grow and they grow and grow
and then, and so this is a material
of gas and dust and the water was
there with other gases and then
if it gets big enough, then
you're also collecting radioactive
materials, I mean, all
rocky material contains some
radioactive elements.
And so that radioactive
material heats up
and you get something big enough
and then you heat it and it melts
and then the heavy stuff
sinks to the center
and the light stiff
floats to the top.
So it's that sort of hand wavy
process of planet formation
that we think results
in what we see today.
So when --
>> Jennifer Harbster: Yeah we
only have time for like one more.
>> Lucy McFadden: One more question.
>> Just since there isn't a fuel
station out there to refuel with,
how do you extend the mission?
Do you just slow down?
>> Lucy McFadden: Okay since
there's no fuel station to refuel,
how do we extend the mission?
So our extended mission will
go until we run out of fuel.
So we've planned to use some
fuel in the low altitude orbit
and the engineers did such a
good job that I think we're going
to have left over fuel, but
we're not going to leave Vesta,
we're not going to leave Ceres.
We'll do something else in
Ceres orbit and we have to,
for planetary protection
because there is water,
because Ceres is a watery body,
we do have to park the spacecraft
in a safe orbit that will
stable for hundreds of years
so that we don't contaminate
the surface of Ceres.
>> Doctor, doctor.
The [inaudible].
>> Lucy McFadden: Of the spacecraft,
what's the weight of the spacecraft?
Hundreds of kilograms.
I'm not really sure.
I'd have to look that up.
So I'm sorry I don't
have that answer.
>> It's listed on a
fact sheet [inaudible].
>> Lucy McFadden: Yeah if
you can find the fact sheet,
it will list it, but I know
that 100 kilograms of fuel
and that's going away, so the
mass is continually getting,
decreasing as we use up the fuel.
[ Inaudible Response ]
Kilometers, no it's going
to be in a stable orbit.
[ Inaudible Response ]
Put it in a stable orbit.
Yes. One last question.
>> Yeah we'll do one more.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Lucy McFadden: Oh
how long does it take
to send the signal and get it back?
Well I didn't do that
calculation either.
Those guys at Goldstone
take care of that for me.
I'd say, I think it's
about 20 minutes,
but you know what we
better calculate
that because we're
three times the distance
and this is how I did
it, but please check me.
The earth is seven minutes
from the sun, light travel time
and then Ceres is about three times
that distance from the sun where,
so the spacecraft is at 3AU,
so I said seven times three,
about 20 minutes, but
I'd really appreciate it
if someone checks my erythematic.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Jennifer Harbster: Thank
you everyone for coming in.
>> Lucy McFadden: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.